[Music]
amnesty international says israel has
built up an array of policies laws
military coercion and economic and
social discrimination that amounts to
oppression and domination over
palestinians in the areas it controls in
short it says a system of apartheid we
are here today
to call on the international community
to take resolute action
against the crime of humanity
being perpetrated
in order to maintain
the system of apartheid
the report highlights last year's
tensions over threatened displacements
of palestinians from their homes in the
sheikh jura neighborhood of occupied
east jerusalem and the military and
communal violence that followed it sets
out a catalogue of instances and
techniques whereby palestinians have
been displaced from land in israel and
in the occupied territories
a settler has confiscated thousands of
hectares while palestinian shepherds
can't graze their sheep we want
protection for our herders from the
settlers but it goes much further back
in israel's history analyzing basic laws
and long-term policies it says designed
to guarantee a jewish majority and
jewish control israel's government says
that is an attempt to paint israel
itself as an inherently racist endeavor
in other words it's an example of
anti-semitism instead of seeking the
truth
amnesty echoes the same lies shared by
terrorist organizations
five minutes of serious examination
would be enough to know that the
so-called facts in the report published
by amnesty this week are
delusional
and disconnected from reality amnesty
calls that a diversion we're not
questioning the fact that there is an
intent or a desire to create a jewish
state what we are saying is that a
jewish state must respect and protect
the right of all people on its
territories this is the third report
within the last year accusing israel of
apartheid after israeli rights group bet
selem and human rights watch reached
similar conclusions amnesty says the
events here in shakespeare in 2021 are
further evidence of the conclusions that
it was making in its report and evidence
of the need for such work to be done it
also says that one of the first things
that israel can do to start unpicking
what it calls an apartheid system is to
protect and restore palestinian homes
such as these amnesty also wants the
findings from this report used in
investigations currently being
undertaken in the international criminal
court and at the united nations harry
fawcett al-jazeera occupied east
jerusalem